So finally, let's look at a little bit
more detail about these types of codes.
So this was our all open shutter,
the sinc function looked like this.
I captured both low and
high frequencies.
Of course, we can just alternate the
shutter, not in a random matter at all,
but just much more in
a time manner like this.
A sinc function also still has low
frequencies and high frequencies,
it just has a different our, you know,
representation doesn't help us much.
Random, we can just run it randomly.
It can, that would allow us to do this,
but again, would have more variations,
would have more peaks and
lows and stuff like that.
What these authors found is some sort
of a flutter starter signal like this,
which went through small, sharp, small,
large, small, large kinds of things.
Gave a sinc function like this that
captured all of the high frequencies,
and that was much more amenable to
the kind of stuff they wanted to do.
Again, the analysis of this
exists in the paper, and
I encourage you to look at it.